más pases sanitarios es la demanda que
comparten las 200 manifestaciones
convocadas en varias ciudades de francia
por noveno sábado consecutivo
en parís cientos de empleados sanitarios
se manifiestan en frente al ministerio
de salud consideran que la exigencia de
la vacuna para trabajar es
antidemocrática usted se da cuenta de lo
que es un cuidador que ha metido a
pacientes en bolsas para cadáveres que
se enfrenta al abuso institucional que
sufre en su trabajo y al que le dicen tú
sigue vacuna te de todos modos si no te
vacunas te suspenderán te quedarás sin
sueldo en qué país democrático hace eso
el gobierno francés anunció que a partir
del 15 de septiembre todos los empleados
de hospitales y residencias de ancianos
podrán ser suspendidos sin pagos si no
han recibido al menos una dosis
y trabajé siendo positiva para kobe
asintomática fui a trabajar todos los
días incluso 40 45 horas y no fue un
problema para nadie realmente para nadie
y hoy por no ponerme esta inyección me
piden que me vaya aunque tenga buena
salud para atender a mis pacientes
mientras que entre los ciudadanos hay
preocupación por los supuestos efectos
secundarios de los fármacos
el hecho de vacunar a los niños desde
los 12 años me preocupa porque no
conocemos las consecuencias de esta
vacuna porque no es una vacuna es una
inyección no conocemos las consecuencias
a largo plazo
el pase sanitario entró en vigor el 9 de
agosto se trata de un documento que
confirma que una persona fue vacunada
contra el joven 19 o tiene una prueba
con resultado negativo de menos de 72
horas y es exigido además para ingresar
a lugares de ocio y trenes de largas
distancias